bonjour antoine alors le président russe
est allé voir les malades hier quelles
sont les craintes du côté de la russie
de quelle manière le pays soit
s'organiser mieux revenir poutine vous
l'avez dit a voulu se rendre compte
lui-même de la réponse apportée par les
autorités ont dans leur visite et un
hôpital moscovite qui accueille
actuellement des patients atteints du
coc vide 19 on l'a vue vêtue d'une
combinaison étanche il est allé à la
rencontre des malades et du personnel
hospitalier lice au passage félicité de
la qualité du travail et de la
coordination des équipes soignantes et
même si le nombre de cas confirmés est
encore relativement peu élevé en russie
aux alentours de 500 d'après le décompte
de 10 hier le médecin chef de l'hôpital
on l'a entendu également a prévenu qu'il
fallait se préparer au pire se préparer
un scénario à l'italienne des craintes
qui sont d'ailleurs partagé par le maire
de moscou qui a doctor début de semaine
des mesures de confinement pour les
personnes âgées ainsi que pour les
personnes les plus fragiles par exemple
celles atteintes de maladies chroniques
ou de maladies respiratoires des mesures
qu'il aimerait d'ailleurs voir étendu au
reste du pays en effet pour lui le
nombre de cas recensés est largement
sous-estimé le problème
d'après le maire de moscou toujours
c'est que le volume de tests effectués
est faible ce qui ne permet pas de se
faire une idée précise de l'ampleur de
la contamination
merci beaucoup antoine claireaux en
direct de moscou